chaos and chaos is a word continues for
spirit airlines and its customers who
are very frustrated and angry this
morning
the low-cost airline has already
canceled more than 250 flights
that brings the total to more than 1700
this week thousands of passengers were
left stranded
spirit blames a perfect storm of staff
shortages and bad weather
errol barnett spoke with spirits
president and ceo that's ted christie
earl is at washington's reagan's
national airport with more on the story
good morning to you errol what else did
he tell you
good morning gail well christy is
apologizing emphatically
to passengers he said their schedule
should be back to normal by next week
but that means more cancellations
through the the weekend now look
this is a budget airline so its
passengers are already
financially conscious and we spoke to
people who spent hundreds of dollars
on hotel stays on car rentals
those who couldn't afford that take a
look at some of this video had to sleep
at baggage claim areas some people in
their own wheelchairs
and from coast to coast this just added
to people's frustrations so we asked
christy
to respond to those videos of people
really suffering at airports with no
place to
go it's heart-wrenching uh it's a
terrible experience and we're doing our
best
to make up for that and i believe we
have so that those
people are either where they belong or
they're in a hotel or or
afforded the option to go somewhere else
now christie says that includes
reimbursing travelers for food even
booking them
on other airlines and he admits the
airline has just simply been
overwhelmed he explains the problems
began late july with bad weather across
the country
that resulted in delays and then
stranded crews
that led to staff shortages and it was
just a real domino effect
he did say the airline should have
cancelled more flights to reset
but instead they tried to stay afloat
maintaining the flights
to accommodate the large number of
passenger bookings they did have
christie tells me that he does want to
win customers back he's committed to
improving the reliability
and the reputation of the airline but
dana this has been such a painful week
for so many people
it remains to be seen just how long it
will take before they trust this airline
again
yeah once you've gone through it it is
very difficult to get people back errol
thank you